whispers of the Nintendo NX have been
circulating forever but we're about to
get even more of them we've heard talk
of detachable controllers Portability
and gesture control and a new patent
from Nintendo falls right in line with
those rumors could we be getting our
first real look at the NX the patent was
filed in January 2016 but was recently
dug up by neogaf it describes an
accessory that can be attached to the
outside of a quote information
processing device looking at the picture
it certainly matches the detachable
controller rumor the patent also
describes an infrared camera in the
device that can read hand gestures or
even mimic button presses when there's
no controller attached maybe flipping
the bird will automatically pause the
game for you patents should always be
taken with a grain of salt but this one
is certainly interesting and considering
the NX is slated for release in March
2017 we should be seeing the official
unveiling in the near future stay tuned
to gamespot as the story develops and to
keep up with all the latest from
Nintendo you're already in the right
place